[Música]
empezamos nuestra sección una revista de
prensa en la que rosa pérez más de eeuu
hoy nos hará un recorrido por como los
medios de nuestra región están cubriendo
el plebiscito que se votó en chile rosa
bienvenida buenos días y un placer para
mí estar hoy con usted acá buenos días
maría clara igualmente rosa comencemos
con los periódicos latinoamericanos
concretamente con la nación de argentina
exactamente que titula aplastante
rechazo a la nueva constitución en chile
boris en problemas y esto lo encontramos
de forma muy recurrente no un poco como
precisamente el presidente chileno ha
estado muy vinculado con la opción del
apruebo por tanto la derrota del apruebo
es al tiempo una derrota para el
gobierno y julia para el gobierno
chileno y que dice clarín sorpresa en
chile por la durísima derrota de boris y
el espectador en colombia chile el
cambio que no fue duro ese titular y en
brasil el correio braziliense señala más
del 61 por ciento rechaza la nueva
constitución bueno y más al norte
cuéntenos cómo lo reporta el new york
times' vamos a hacer énfasis un poco en
las que señala este medio de eeuu que
dice si le dice no a la constitución
izquierdista tras tres años de debate
entendemos estos tres años pues desde
2019 que estallaron estas protestas que
al final desencadenaron no en la en el
referendo de entrada para redactar una
nueva constitución y finalmente en este
referendo de salida en que se ha
rechazado la propuesta constitucional
pero esta propuesta precisamente el 'new
york times' la señala como que habría
legalizado el aborto establecido sanidad
universal y consagrado más de 100
derechos un récord mundial bueno y si
esto buscaba la nueva constitución
chilena yo supongo que los medios de
otras ideologías han titulado distinto
como es el caso de granma en cuba pues
se señala que el plebiscito ha estado
marcado por una gran polarización y
también por una gran campaña de
informaciones falsas particularmente
veamos al literalmente un extracto dice
varios expertos coinciden que este
resultado es consecuencia de una amplia
campaña de desinformación y de un
incentivo con muchísimo dinero para el
texto bueno siguiendo en esta misma
línea nos vamos hasta china que dice el
south china morning post' que chile
rechaza ampliamente renovar la
constitución de la era de la dictadura
bueno y en el caso de los chilenos que
están reportando los medios como el
mercurio y la tercera en primer lugar
recordemos que el mercurio es un medio
abiertamente de derechas que en su
momento incluso apoyó la dictadura de
pinochet no hoy titula con un resultado
numérico señalando que el 61,9 por
ciento de los votantes apoyó el rechazo
lo que se traduce en 7 millones
881 mil votos que sólo este grueso de
votos supera la participación total en
el plebiscito de entrada a lo que nos
referíamos anteriormente cuando en 2020
el 78 por ciento de los votantes
apoyaron redactar una nueva constitución
y precisamente dice que uno de los
motivos del rechazo es una agenda de
cambios radicales y la tercera que hoy
se señala chile rechaza la propuesta
constitucional con una amplia y una
participación histórica pero insistimos
en que esta participación histórica
viene dada porque el voto era
obligatorio recordemos no hubo 13
millones de chilenos que acudieron a las
urnas de unos a 15 que estaban llamados
a ellas bueno y antes de seguir
recordemos con el comentado editorial
que publicó el washington post previo al
club y si tú chileno exactamente porque
este editorial señora señala de forma
muy clara los intereses económicos que
hubo detrás de la campaña del rechazo a
este plebiscito porque recordemos que la
constitución entre otras cosas brindaba
una cierta protección del medio ambiente
que limitaría la actividad minera en el
país no y señalamos algunas de las
frases de este editorial que se titula
chile debe reescribir la propuesta y el
'washington post' escribía el litio es
un material clave en las baterías de
millones de computadores en los cuales
eeuu basa su futuro automovilístico
eléctrico chile tiene las principales
reservas de litio del mundo aporta el 25
por ciento de los suministros del a
nivel mundial solo esta razón ya es
suficiente para estar atentos al
plebiscito que podría reducir el margen
legal de extracción en la en la nación
latinoamericana donde ha regido durante
18 años un tratado de libre comercio con
eeuu bueno ya vimos que diferentes
posturas de los medios con diferente
información tanto antes del plebiscito
como después rosa y usted qué opina
sobre sus titulares bien que hay ciertos
rasgos en común no que no se pueden
obviar precisamente esta derrota del
gobierno no porque como decíamos ha
vinculado su mandato de forma muy
estrecha con la opción de la prueba y
precisamente una de las primeras
reacciones de gabriel boric ha sido ya
un cambio de gabinete y también digamos
el hecho de que la derecha haya optado
por el rechazo desde hace un año desde
antes que se escribieran los primeros
artículos pero que al final haya
señalado que a optar por el rechazo en
este plebiscito no significa digamos
evitar totalmente un cambio de
constitución pues ha fracturado
muchísimo la sociedad y justo eso es lo
que vamos a analizar rosa con nuestro
primer invitado del día gracias por
estar con nosotros